This is a video I'm making for the young
man who stopped me on the street of
Rodeo Drive and said that he had made
$80,000 doing sales and he stopped
because he was no longer passionate
about it. And you asked me, "What should
I do with my life?" And I didn't have
time to answer you when I was walking,
but I wanted to give you a longer answer
right now. You said you stopped because
you didn't think sales was your passion.
And what really got me thinking about
that is that I actually was in your
position. I had a management consulting
job. I saved up $50,000 from that job.
And then I said, I'm not passionate
about this. I'm going to go do something
that I am passionate about, which at the
time was fitness. And for those of you
who are new to my channel, I took
fitness and went full cycle all the way
to a $46 million exit. But I want to
give you the steps in between there and
tell you how it actually ended up today
because fitness is still a passion of
mine. So then why don't I do it as my
business? I was a consultant, right? And
I did the same thing and I was
miserable. And so then I started the
free training project which was like a
nonprofit where I just did people's
workouts for them. And I was like, "Oh,
this is cool." And then I figured maybe
I could do this for profit. Like
wouldn't that be the dream? Never work
another day in my life. And what was
interesting is that as more and more
customers came in, I started to get
tired of actually making so many
programs. And so then I was like, maybe
if I just like start a gym, that's the
real deal, right? And so then I signed a
lease, put all the money I had into
getting this gym going. And it was the
hardest thing that I've ever done. I
came into it thinking that I'd be
training like the star athletes, right?
But I wasn't. I actually found out I was
training lots of moms who wanted to lose
weight and didn't really care that much
about fitness. And even in the few
moments where I had just maybe one
person that showed an inkling of
interest in fitness to the degree that I
was, it still got kind of boring because
I ended up having to do the same thing
over and over and over again. And so the
difficult part with that specific part
of my passion journey is that I couldn't
get out of it because I already signed a
lease, right? I had to just keep going.
The reason I'm making this is because
your passions and your interests are
often incredibly narrow. And addiction
is a narrowing of things that bring you
joy. Fulfillment is a broadening of
them. Fast forward. So then I scale up
the gyms and then I start doing
turnarounds, flying across the country,
filling up other people's gyms cuz I
really got good at marketing and sales.
Then I licensed that model, 6,000
locations. I started a supplement
company, sell through that distribution
base. And then I sold all of that to
private equity at a $46.2 million
valuation. And the reason that I find
this so interesting is that today
I still love fitness and I don't talk
about it because I actually don't want
it to mix with my life in a weird way.
Like it's this kind of like holy grail
for me. And I have an amazing HQ job.
And so then it begs the question, wait a
second, why don't you do your passion?
Because if you did your passion, you
wouldn't work another day in your life.
And it's just a very simplistic and
inaccurate view of the world. There's
only one way that you will truly be able
to only do your passion.
It means that you would only do this
very narrow thing, right? For me at the
time was training more advanced athletes
who liked powerlifting and had the same
work capacity and schedule as me, who
were willing to pay me tons of money to
do it. Right? In order to get those
people, you have to do a lot of stuff
that is not that to get them. The vast
majority of your time will not be
anything that you're passionate about.
And if that's the case, even when you're
pursuing your passion, and I'm saying
this as someone who's gone full cycle
with this, I now have a gym that has no
memberships and it is not for profit.
And I'm saying this that it is okay to
make money doing one thing and be
passionate about another. And uh I I
recently filmed something where I was
showing my home gym to Coupe from uh
Garage Gym Reviews. Shout out to Coupe.
Great guy. If you're into home gyms, you
check out his channel. Not affiliated.
And he asked if I would invest in an
equipment business. And the answer is
yes, but not because it's a passion. I
do have a deep interest and I know a lot
about it, but like think about what it
really means to own an equipment
company. I got to source metals. I'm not
really passionate about that. I got to
figure out logistics. Not really
passionate about that. I'm going to
probably have to go reach out to
different in influencers and get them to
start using my pieces and sending it out
to them and getting feedback on not
really a passion. But all of those
things are required to build this
business around the thing that I'm
passionate about. And so the reason I'm
making this is that most of the [__]
sucks even if it starts as something you
love. The passion is a very bad judgment
filter. Everything within a business,
especially if you're if you're the
owner, will suck because business is a
funneling mechanism of the hardest and
worst problems related to the thing that
you supposedly love. Elon Musk talks
about this where he says
there are problems that are too hard for
anyone else to solve or problems that
are too painful that no one else like
either can't solve it or they don't want
to solve it. And so you have this idea,
I'm going to I'm going to pursue what
I'm passionate about. I'm going to paint
paintings all day. even then quickly
you're going to be outpaced by the
amount of paintings that you can
probably produce. And so I said there's
only one way that you can truly do the
passion is that you do not scale. You
choose to make paint your painting. You
choose to make your wallets. You choose
to do your level of consulting or
whatever it is. And you only do the
amount that you feel like doing and you
only do it when you feel like doing it.
And you're so good at doing that that
people come and spend more and more
money with you and you just increase
your prices. That is the only way that I
can conceive someone would actually
purely do only what they're passionate
about and still be able to make a
living. Now, collecting the payments,
still doing the sales, setting up the
website, paying your taxes, doing the
accounting, sourcing materials, going on
the things to go get the inspiration,
none of that is probably stuff you're
passionate about. And so,
I say this because it's not true. pursue
your passion is only true in the vague
and never in the specific. When you
actually play it out, when you stop just
believing the the [__] saying and
just think, what does this really mean,
it doesn't pencil, and I only say this
as somebody who [__] went all the way
with it. All right? I was into fitness
and I started the gyms and I scaled the
gyms and I did the turnarounds and I
scaled to 6,000 locations. I started the
supplement company. I started the
software company, sold all of it to
private equity. I did the whole thing
and what do I have today? a gym that has
no members and I love it, but it's not
what I make money on. And I say this
because you are fooling yourself. You're
using the excuse of passion
to disguise your inability to tolerate
hardness.
And so a huge amount of success really
comes down to just executing day in and
day out and solving problems
intelligently and making decisions that
are harder short term and easier long
term and sitting in the discomfort of
unsolved problems that aren't the
biggest problems of the day. That is how
you grow a business. And so your passion
likely won't get you very far. Chris
Rock has a great saying. He says,
"Follow your dreams if they're hiring."
And so, you have to embrace how much it
will suck and put yourself in no fail
situations. A big part of why I even
think I was able to stick with the gym
business after realizing that I no
longer spent almost any of my time doing
the thing I was passionate about was
because I couldn't get out of the lease.
And that was all my net worth was in
there. And so, there was nothing else I
could do. And so, I had to make it work.
And so your proficiencies will take you
much further than your passions. Imagine
this. And I I used to think about this a
lot. Imagine farmers thousands of years
ago, right? They probably weren't
passionate about rice or corn or
soybeans,
but they felt a duty and a pride in
providing. And I think that we need to
bring that back. The idea that a man can
do his duty and feel good for a job well
done knowing that you did an honest
day's work and that you left everything
that you had in the field. You have
nothing left in the tank. Hey, and real
quick, I spent 200 hours this year just
making this one project for you, which
is the $100 million scaling road map.
And I broke up the stages of business
into 10 stages. And you can identify
where you're at by simply just putting
in your business information. You go to
acquisition.comroadmap
and it'll spit out this custom report
that tells you what the constraints are
at that current level and what you need
to do to graduate and get to the next
level. This is our gift to you
absolutely free. On the thank you page,
you can book a call with our team and
we'd love to help you uh figure that out
and ideally get past it. And so, let me
tell you a story. friend of mine was a
personal trainer uh then thought that
like high-end cookies was an interesting
market and so he started a high-end
baker even higher end than than than
Crumble is. And knocked it out of the
park, crushed it. And I remember asking
him, I was like, "So, are you like
really passionate about cookies?" He
like laughed. He was like, "No." And I
was like, "Wait, then why would you do
this?" And he was like,
"Because I'm passionate about being
excellent."
And that was such a powerful reframe for
me that I have taken with me for the
rest of my life. Do I love business? I
think I have grown to love business
because I've gotten good at it. And so
when I heard him say that, for me it was
like the ultimate unlock of like that is
what I am passionate about. I'm
passionate about my values and I will
let my values show through in how I do
business rather than saying that the
business and what I do every day must be
the thing. Every goal worth pursuing has
so much pain between where you are and
where you want to go that you trying to
say, "I only want to do the thing I'm
passionate about," is a weak excuse. It
will not get you through it. And so, to
go back to that young man who had his
$80,000 savings, he had barely scratched
the surface of his potential in sales.
There is so much more to the game than
that. And the lesson he probably needed
was learning to be consistent after
something gets boring.
Because that is where people fall off.
Is where it gets boring. Not even hard.
It's where you do the same thing over
and over and over again. And you want to
go nuts cuz you're like, I can't read
the script again. I can't make yet
another ad. Before this video today, I
just did ad recordings where I read
hooks that we know converted with body
copy that we know converted so that we
could say, "Hey, if you're a business
owner and you're looking to scale up for
next year, come to one of our
workshops." This year, if we include the
book launch, I've made somewhere in the
neighborhood of probably 5,000 ads this
year. I started making ads 14 years ago.
Every single week I would record the ads
so I could run ads to get customers so I
could pay my rent. I could payroll. I
could pay the insurance. I could pay for
the the equipment that got broken. I
could pay for the new boom box because
they were complaining that mine wasn't
good enough. I say this because I wasn't
like, "Oh, I'm so passionate about
making ads. I'm so like, no, but I do
want to do a good job." And I think
that's something we can strive to go
through where we can translate the
difficulty into a reinforcing event. Let
me explain this. This is important.
We will do the things that we are
reinforced for doing. Now, many people
conflate that idea with we will do the
things that we rewarded for. No, we will
do the things that we are reinforced for
doing. Let me explain. If I said I have
to shock you, you would probably say
this is a punishing event. Okay. What if
I then said your family, your wife, kids
are on the other side of the the wall.
Every shock that you take, they don't
have to take. Are you going to take
another shock? Yes. Why? Because it's a
reinforcing event. So that's how
something negative can still be
something positive. Let's flip it
differently. If I said for every one of
these shocks, you get a million dollars.
You'd probably be pretty down to take
some shocks, right? Interestingly
though, your willingness to take shocks
over time would go down because the
reinforcing event would need more
variety.
Kind of fun. Anyways, point is I think
the unlock is not trying to pursue your
passions,
but to be compassionate about the
difficulty of the pursuit in who you
become
through that. And to be clear, when
you're responding to emails and you get
a refund or you get a charge back, in
that moment, you're not going to be
like, I love the impact that I'm making.
No, you just have to get used to eating
[__] because it is your duty. because
you made a decision and you made a
commitment to the people that you love
that you want to provide for them. Now,
if you're not somebody who provides for
anyone yet and you just provide for you,
amazing. And at some point in your
entrepreneurial journey, you're going to
have other people's families who rely on
your decisions. You can't take days off
because it's not about you anymore. It's
about everyone, even in the the first
levels, the people who work for you. You
should hopefully be even closer to them
than you are to the customers that you
ultimately serve. Zooming back out,
listen to every mega successful
entrepreneur. The ones who are honest
will tell you one thing across the board
is it sucked and it sucked for way
longer than I thought it would suck and
it sucked way worse than I expected it
would. I don't even like saying passion.
Interests get you started. Proficiency
keeps you going, but pain tolerance
helps you finish. And so I can only say
this about me, which is that I was so
afraid of failing that I know that I
would have kept going until someone
physically prevented me. And so Phil
Knight tells the story in Shoe Dog where
he says, "You're not out of business
when your bank account runs out." He
said, "You're out of business when you
have padlocks on your door and people
physically stop you from doing work."
The main point of this is that the rules
society pretends to have, they are made
up. Until someone physically restrains
you from working, you can keep going.
The vast majority of people stop because
of perceived failure in their mind. And
I love this quote by Jaco Willick. He
said, "All failure besides death is
psychological.
It's literally made up stakes with
madeup goal lines that we decide that we
fell short of. But we were the ones who
decided where to draw the line. And so
to the same degree to that young man who
quit sales early in the career cuz he
wanted to find something he's passionate
about. The reality is that it doesn't
matter what path he chooses to take. All
of them will include tons of stuff that
he will hate doing and that he will have
to keep doing for extended periods of
time. And that in the pain of having to
do these repeated things that you are
not enjoying, what do you think you do?
You try and figure out better ways to do
them so that you hate them less. And
what do you think that is? It's called
getting better. The skill deficiency
that you might have and that this young
man might have, that many people have is
something called frustration tolerance.
It's the number of times that you can be
rejected and try again. And here's the
best part. It's learnable, which means
it's a skill. So, let me give you an
example. So, think of the guy at the
club who tries to make out with every
girl. In romance, very cringy. Do not do
that. But in business, if no one knows
how many times you go up to the next
door and you knock on the next thing or
you send the next email, you're bound to
find an opportunity, which the reason
the guy in the club still does that is
because when he does it, eventually a
door opens.
He wouldn't keep doing it if it didn't
work. As cringey as that may sound, but
one of the early lessons that I wish
someone had told me, and I want to
transfer it to you now, is that when you
start, you will be cringey as [__] You
will be awkward. You will be weird.
People will look at you, the people
you're friends with, people you're
dating, hopefully not for long, will
will make you feel like you're being not
cool. And the reality is they're right.
Because when you start, you will suck.
and you will have no reputation. You
will have no track record. And is that a
reason to not do it
if you're a loser? Yes. Because it means
that you care more about their
disappointment in you than your own
disappointment in you.
And some people never care enough about
their own opinion that they let everyone
else's opinions literally rule the rest
of their lives. And these are people who
won't even be at your funeral.
people who you're going to you went to
high school with, people you went to
college with, people that you're
co-workers.
You know, there's probably right now in
your head you're like, "Oh, what would
other people say?" There's probably only
four people, three people whose opinions
you actually care about, might even just
be one. And if you can stop saying other
people or thinking about this vagueness
of it and get really specific and say,
"What's the name of the person? Whose
actual voice am I hearing?" If you then
just get to ask the question, is this
person's opinion of how I live my life
going to be the most important thing
that I spend the next 80 years listening
to? If the answer is yes, then I mean,
more power to you. But I don't know
about you, I wouldn't want the one voice
that I'm listening to for the rest of my
life be some random dude that I worked
with or my uncle that said something or
my dad or my mom or your sister,
whatever. Because the only real voice
that you actually have to listen to
that's not made up is yours.
You need frustration tolerance. Sitting
in the unknown with the confidence that
you will continue to try because it is
solvable even though you don't know how
to solve it yet. It just comes down to
that. It comes down to knocking on more
doors. It comes down to trying to build
the web page again when there's a bug
and it doesn't work. It comes down to
spending money on ads even though it
doesn't give you any ROI, saving up your
money and doing it again. It comes to
posting another video even though you
got negative comments or people are
like, "Maybe you should try something
else." Hey, they're just doing it
because they they care about you.
They're doing it because they they want
the best for you. They don't want you to
pursue this path and it's, you know,
you're really not meant for it, right?
Of course, you're not [__] meant for
it. You just started. Of course, you're
not good. How do you think anyone gets
good? You suck for a long time and you
get a little bit better until you suck
so little that you're actually good. And
that sucking period, slow down, takes a
long time. It takes a long time to get
through that. And that is frustration
tolerance. How many times can you do the
same thing without reward, without
reinforcement, and keep going? That is
the hard part because it's very
difficult to observe that. We just had
somebody who started on our YouTube team
and he said it's a different thing. He's
like, "I've watched all your videos.
I've seen all your stuff." He said,
"It's a different energy being here at
4:00 a.m. and then seeing you at 4:00
a.m. here and then being here on Sunday
at 4 and seeing you at 4:00 and seeing
that every single day." And to be clear,
I'm not always there at 4. I'm there at
4, sometimes 5:00, sometimes 6. All
right? But every single day, seeing
that, he was like, it really shifted my
perspective in terms of like, he's like,
"You're where you're at now and you're
still working like this." I bring this
up to say that like it is far more
politically correct and convenient for
me when someone asks what's your advice
to someone who's starting out is to say
follow your passion. And it's because no
one will fight you. And because you
can't say I was smarter than most
people. That's not correct. Can't say
that. You can't say I had advantages.
They were given to me. That's not going
to really fly super well. I mean it'll
be okay. You can't say I was just pure
luck. Can't say that. And so they
default to something that every everyone
just like move on with your life when
you say follow something you're
passionate about. I I think I've gotten
to a point and this is a weird
transition that I'm in right now being
honest where I I I I really I think my
like I mean I still have some [__] to
give but a huge [__] just went out the
back door. I really do not need to do
this at all financially. Zero.
And I think about, well, I have to do
something for the rest of my life. And I
would like it to be something that helps
other people in some way. And so, I'm
willing to be hated for some stances
that I take that I believe to be true,
even though they are unpopular. And even
if they make me look cringe for saying
them, which is that you have to learn to
suffer
and you have to learn to suffer for
something that you deem worth suffering
for.
And I don't know of anything more
valuable to suffer for than the person
that you ultimately want to become, the
man that you want to become, the woman
that you want to become.
And when I think about that man,
I think about how much suffering would
that man have to go through to become
the person that I envision.
Is it the amount of suffering that I've
been through? Not even close. But that
means that I have to go through even
more than I've been through right now to
become that person. And so I then think,
okay, well, is there an alternative
path? What if I just stop gassing it
now? What if I just stop making videos?
I don't have to deal with any of these
comments. I don't have to deal with any
of the hate videos that I get made,
right? I don't have to deal with the
people calling me fake guru or grifter.
Like I [__] like all my go grab it.
It's free. All right. I wouldn't have to
deal with any of that.
But then I think about that man that I
want to be and him looking looking at me
looking back into today.
Would he be proud of that decision?
And the answer is no. And then that
shame that I feel for not living up to
that man's standards is what gets me
back in the ring. And so I don't know
what that man or that woman looks like
for you. And if you already are that
person, more power to you. But most of
the people that I talk to, especially a
lot of the young men that I talk to,
they feel like they're very far away
from the man that they want to be. And
what they have not learned is the amount
of pain and frustration that you will
have to go through on a consistent basis
in order to become that person. And I'm
not saying that cuz it will always be
ahead of you, right? Like you will never
meet your potential. Like until you die,
you won't know, right? And once you're
dead, you won't know either because
you'll be dead. But I think the goals
that are worth pursuing are goals that
we cannot achieve while we are alive. I
think this whole follow your passion
thing is almost like the Hollywood love
story movies, right? It's very
convenient. It fits within a 90minute
story arc, but at the end of every one
of the fairy tales, now they're married.
Now they've got 50 years together and he
doesn't like picking up his socks and
she wants to have her own career, but he
wants support in his career. So, how are
they going to reconcile those
differences? Right? Reality. And to be
clear, I don't think people who say
follow your passion have any melon in
all. And I think that also when you look
back on your own career, you have
rosecolored glasses and you think, "Oh,
I'm so glad. I love what I went
through." It's like, "No, no, no.
Nostalgia is memory minus pain." So,
think about your life when you're like,
"Oh, nostalgia. I remember when we used
to live here." It's like, "Yeah, you
were stressed out of your [__] mind
because we had to pay rent every month.
That's what I remember when we lived
here. Oh, I remember when we were young
and broke. Those are the good old days."
It's like, yeah, if you forget about the
fact that you were constantly in
existential dread, didn't know what you
were doing, had no skills that you had
that you could trade for any appreciable
amount of money, working all the hours
that you had, and still not really
making any meaningful progress,
sacrificing the few things that you
could have had with your youth to have
something that is completely unknown in
the future, all off the idea of just
some hope or dream that you have that it
might work out in someday in the future.
And everyone questioning you and you
questioning yourself the whole way
because you're like, am I being
delusional? I'm the only person of the
people that I know that's even trying to
do this. And you will be different
because you want to live a different
life than them. And that makes sense.
It's just difficult because you will be
in the minority. And most of your life,
most of our lives as humans, we are
taught to do what the pack does. The
whole class gets in line, you get in
line, right? If the whole class gets up
to leave the class, you get you leave
class. Whole class goes to lunch, you go
to lunch, you go to recess, right? You
do everything together. Being the odd
man out is not fun. It's out group. It
literally was a survival mechanism. But
you have to go against that very hard
wiring to become the man or woman that I
think you ultimately want to be. Or at
least for me, that's what I had to do.
And so to that young man that I that
that stopped me on Rodeo Drive, is sales
your life path? I don't know. Is it
wholesaling? Is it real estate? Is it
starting a marketing agency? I don't
know. But what I do know is that every
single one of those paths you can be
successful on. I also know that every
single one of those paths will suck and
will take longer than you expect they
will. And I also know that every single
winner that I have ever spoken to, I can
see in them that they have one thing,
which is that they will just keep
[__] going. They will not know what's
going to happen next and they will keep
going. They will fail and they will try
again. And there's something incredibly
dangerous about being the type of man
that no matter what happens, your
competitors know that you will not stop
because there's literally nothing they
can do unless you get killed. Besides
that, they know that you're going to get
up and try again. And when you try that
many times for the rest of your life on
one thing, you tend to get pretty
[__] good at it. And when you get
pretty [__] good at something, you
become very hard to stop. Hopefully that
helps you which is pick a path and
commit to the path because the person
you want to be is at the end of it and
everything between you now and that man
then is the pain that you have to learn
to get through and by the time you learn
how to get through that pain you will be
that